now the Pentagon says a US warship has
destroyed drones and missiles fired
towards it and three other commercial
ships in the Red Sea the US says the
drones and missiles were launched from
territory held by the houti rebels in
Yemen the hooti sa two of the ships it
targeted were linked to Israel but the
Israelis have denied
this our forces will continue to prevent
all the Israeli ships from sailing in
the Arab and Red Sea until all the
aggression against Gaza stops the Yemen
Armed Forces continue to warn all the
Israeli naval ships and All Ships linked
to Israel that they will become a
legitimate Target if they refuse to
comply all right well I'm pleased to
interview introduce Nabil kururi who's a
former US Diplomat and former deputy
chief of Mission to Yemen he joins us
from Washington DC a very warm welcome
to you so these three commercial ships
and this us warship the USS Carney were
targeted by hooti drones as I said but
why is this
happening from the uh Hui perspective
they are demonstrating solidarity with
the Palestinians in Gaza uh they are
also trying to play a part in what is
known as the axis of resistance uh
principally for them hisbah of Lebanon
uh they over the past few years have
been integrated closer and closer into
that axis and uh what is doing along the
Lebanese border is engaging the Israelis
and diverting some of the Israeli
resources from the south in Gaza to the
North in Lebanon the huis are trying to
do the same thing um by distracting the
Israelis and causing the Israelis to
devote some deployments to the Red Sea
right at this point though the Hui
action is remains limited right can can
you explain this the Strategic
significance of this particular shipping
Lane why is it potentially a disruptive
Target well uh even though so far it's
only uh cargo civilian cargo ships that
have been targeted this is a Lifeline uh
for Europe and much of uh the rest of
the world uh bulk of oil shipments from
the Gulf go through the sez Canal Med
Mediterranean then onto uh Europe and
not just oil oil natural gas uh other
Freight goes through that and if these
incidents continue either uh shipping
companies will stop shipping will divert
it will cost them more to divert uh
their path and insurance rates will go
up right and uh at some
point somebody us principally perhaps
Britain would will start taking action
to stop this right so it's a way of
inflicting I guess a degree of economic
Warfare as well so if these drones were
fired from Yemen as at the US ship why
then Are We Now hearing about the US
carrying out a so-called selfdefense
strike in Iraq against an apparent drone
staging site there what does that mean
within the context of this axis of
resistance that you've
described well um so far the US has not
despite its full support for Israel and
politically and in terms of intelligence
and material it has not joined the fight
uh in a direct way uh they have all the
American forces have only responded to
direct attacks on them sometimes in
Syria sometimes in Iraq and occasionally
now as we see at sea but they have not
really taken the full offensive against
the anti-us force in Iraq um the US
would rather not uh see a widening of
this war and if they engage directly it
will certainly be much wider than what
we've seen so far um there does appear
to be a con some kind of a conflict of
opinion between the Biden Administration
and the Netanyahu Administration in
Israel but so far frankly the US
position is somewhat
contradictory because it says things to
Israel which it should know that Israel
cannot comply with there is no way that
Israel can proceed uh as it was going on
in the northern part of Gaza in the
South without hurting civilians it's
just not possible so this Administration
I know is receiving information analysis
and advice from various agencies of the
US government that this is not possible
that this is not going to end well but
uh President Biden personally is
insistent okay Nabil curri great to hear
your thoughts on that many thanks